I I I'm still open to anything I'll
believe in anything if it's convenient
anything at all I I you know I I wasn't
opposed I definitely didn't know uh God
existed but I didn't know he didn't I
wasn't sure in any direction and I'm
still not I I don't uh astrology
it's a good example I don't believe in
astrology unless
somebody doesn't like me
and then I only believe in astrology
what she said what
what month was she born in
[Applause]
of course she was born in November
astrology's a great religion if you need
to to explain why people don't like you
Christianity is a great religion if you
need to explain why you don't like
people
foreign